americans have shattered records for
online shopping
since the pandemic began some analysts
predict online sales could hit
10 billion dollars today and reach
nearly 190 billion dollars over the
holiday season
but the federal trade commission says
cyber crime involving social media has
more than tripled in the last year
our consumer investigative correspondent
anna warner shows us the danger signs
anna good to see you good morning
good to see you jerica good morning yes
legitimate merchants are hoping for a
windfall that could lift their profits
in a tough year but
guess what scammers may be too and it
can be difficult to tell
what's real and what's not i've learned
my lesson
tennessee great-grandmother debbie
jackson says she learned how someone can
fall for an
online scam it started when she ordered
a special christmas present for her
two-year-old great grandson
asher a gift of a three foot tall toy
dinosaur that's the other facebook page
that the same ad was on
this ad on facebook showed kids riding
the dinosaur
so jackson says she ordered one for
roughly 200 dollars through the seller's
facebook page christina lewis is asher's
mom
it was supposed to be a riding dinosaur
that had a little button that he could
press and it would make
noises and be interactive and so we're
like
awesome this is great he's gonna love it
for christmas
but when the toy arrived in florida it
is a
stuffed animal about this big didn't
even look like
the dinosaur and so what do you call
that
it's a scam for sure
the real toy comes from play school and
the commercial is theirs too
but lewis says it appears the scammers
used the real ad to sell that cheap
much smaller knockoff it's really
upsetting that there's scammers out
there that are just
putting a bad taste in people's mouth
about online shopping
i was really on facebook and instagram
just kind of scrolling
christina white from irving texas saw an
ad from what she thought was a
legitimate seller on facebook marketing
a body slimming cream
it brought me up to the site i looked at
it read a couple of the reviews
and i was like okay seems legitimate
let me go ahead and try it you know it's
26 25 26 bucks
what do i have to lose what she lost she
says was close to 25
bucks the product never arrived those
stories are being heard more often
during the pandemic says judith bitterly
from security firm mcafee
what we know is that cyber criminals
follow the money and the money is online
now
her company found cyber crime up 12
percent since april
419 cyber threats per minute
so it's a barrage it is a barrage and
she says criminals aren't just after the
cash
through gift card scams and fake
websites they try to trick consumers
into giving up their private information
customers will see a deal that may be
too good to be true
priced really low they'll go there and
ultimately their personal information
will end up on the dark web or being
stolen
they're after the money and your
identity is valuable
since many scams start on social media
facebook is now teaming up with the
better business bureau to warn online
shoppers
donating 75 000 worth of ad space to the
bbb
for ads like these facebook's sarah
schiff
our systems are constantly improving and
we're evolving our policies to get ahead
of people trying to scam
people out of money and break our rules
but debbie jackson says her experience
on facebook has made her skeptical
they've got more money than god why in
the world would they
not be able to find a problem because
that isn't the first time
i mean it's the first time i fell for it
but you know it's going to be the last
well the website that jackson bought the
toy from is no longer active
uh the website that white bought her
cream from is we reached out to them for
a response but
have not yet heard back facebook said in
its last
enforcement report it had removed 1.3
billion
fake accounts from the platform so vlad
that gives you an idea of how many are
out there
yeah and uh excellent reporting as
always you know my wife sometimes says
i'm a spending mix benderson
but i generally like to go to the
website that's legit i don't look like
deals
because i don't want to get caught in a
situation like that in other words i
look for the seller
or the company that actually makes them
right right
i only give that kind of personal
information with reputable companies
companies i'm familiar with
where i use something like paypal to
right to you know be an intermediary to
ensure
that my my my uh purchase goes through
yeah
yeah it's important it's important for
people to understand the risks that are
out there
if you see a really great deal and you
want to take advantage of it you got to
be careful
yeah and a warner is always with that
excellent consumer reporting thank you
anna